PIOTR STEINKILLER: Welcome.
I'm Piotr Steinkeller.
I teach Assyriology and Ancient
Mesopotamian history and Religion
at Harvard.
And today I would like to share
with you a very special cuneiform
tablet which belongs to the collection
of the Harvard Semitic Museum.
It is one of the most important
cuneiform tablets in our collection.
It dates roughly to 1,700 BCE, the
reign of the great Hammurabi of Babylon.
It is written in the Akkadian language.
What makes this tablet so unique--
it is a manual of the divination.
a priest called baru, in Akkadian--
another term from him is haruspex--
and he was a specialist,
ritual specialist,
who foretold future from the
appearance of sheep's intestines.
The tablet contains 142 lines.
This is what we call the
frontside, or the obverse.
OK, so this is the beginning
of the tablet here.
I would like to point out that the
scribe is incredibly small and tiny.
It's quite unusual in that way.
So we have probably something like 60
lines over the front or the obverse,
and then the tablet
continues on the back.
The reverse of the tablet, up to here.
The manual tells the diviner
what he may find in the exta,
and how he should honorize the exta.
The text begins with ritual
instructions for the diviner, which
instruct him how he should
invite the gods to the extispicy.
And the central figure
here is the sun god.
And how he may ask the gods to obtain
a favorable answer to his query.
So he should offer offerings,
prepare offerings, say some prayers,
and then he should sacrifice a sheep.
Having slaughtered the sheep, he then
should ask the sun god and other gods
for a positive answer.
And they are supposed to inscribe
the answer in the entrails
of the sacrificial sheep.